two women have been killed and another
injured in an alleged Palestinian
shooting attack in the West Bank now
this is all according to Israeli Medics
who say the two women were in their
twenties and they say another 45 year
old woman was seriously wounded near the
Jewish settlement of Hamra in the
occupied territory the Israeli military
said security forces were searching for
the attacker who opened fire
their car apparently carrying the women
then crashed now this all comes after
Israeli forces launched airstrikes on
Lebanon and Gaza earlier today the
fighting follows clashes at Jerusalem's
most sensitive holy site at a time when
Muslims and Jews are celebrating
religious festivals Skies Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel has more
on the exchanges earlier today well
let's just go back to yesterday
afternoon when a couple of salvos of
rockets were fired out of Southern
Lebanon into Northern Israel the most
Rock it's fired since read the 2006 war
is the general calculation so quite an
escalation on a different front in
response the IDF hit targets overnight
both in southern Lebanon and in Gaza and
the reason that they struck those two
locations is because they hold Hamas the
group that controls Gaza and has a small
presence in Lebanon as being responsible
for those rocket attacks from Lebanon so
they targeted things like weapon storage
is tunnels some research and development
Laboratories as well in Gaza a
children's hospital was just hit as
collateral damage not badly hit but was
we understand
um hit by some shrapnel because one of
the strikes as well which would have
been really frightening for the children
inside that hospital the IDF say that
they're looking into what happened there
but no reports of major casualties the
um the authorities and the militia in
Gaza in return fired Rockets into
Southern Israel as well in excess of 40
Rockets many of those were intercepted
by the Iron Dome defense system some of
them went into the sea some of them fell
short but one did hit a home in the town
of Sarat in terms of well behind me
Alexa mosque which has been the scene of
violence over the last couple of days
that was quiet last night it's quiet
again this morning Friday prayers will
take place in a few hours time but this
weekend could be quite crucial and
that's the way Israeli intelligence are
seeing it because you've got that
convergence of three religious festivals
Ramadan Passover and Easter of course
and so I think there's a real height
intention as we go into this weekend and
what might happen in that respect both
sides saying they don't want an
escalation conflict but it is so fragile
at the moment that it wouldn't take much
to trigger that